hey guys
welcome back to another video by simply
learn in today's session we're going to
learn about the ng switch directive
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so talking about ng switch director it
is same as the switch statement in c
programming it specifies an expression
to match against
now the expressions to match are
generally provided within the ng switch
case directives
remember that every view that matches is
rendered onto the view
and if there are no matches a view with
the ng switch default directive is
rendered
and the elements within the entry switch
statement but outside of the ng switch
case
or ng switch default directive are
preserved at the location
to understand the working of this
directive let's head to our text editor
that is vs code
so here i've created a project called
switch and within which i've created
a component called new component so here
in the dot ts file first let's go ahead
and create
a day property so this day specifies the
day of the week
so let's say public
day and this day is going to receive the
day of the week
so for that i'll have to make use of the
date method
so let's say new date
dot get day all right
so basically it returns the current day
okay so let me just save this and back
in my html file
here i've just added a simple good
morning message
and now i'm going to make use of the div
tag
and say ng switch
and i'm going to be making use of the
day property so i'll just say equals
day all right
and now i'm going to make use of
the ng switch case directive so let's
say div
ng switch case
so one thing to remember is that when
you're making use of the get day method
here
it returns a value that is a digit so it
returns 0 for a sunday
and 6 for a saturday so what we do is
here
it's going to be an integer so when i
say ng switch case
equals 0
i say let's just display a message
saying today is
sunday you deserve a break
or something like that a simple message
so i'm gonna add the switch case for the
rest of the
days of the week if it's a monday i'm
gonna display a
separate message and if it's a tuesday
wednesday and the rest of the days of
the week all right
so lastly i'm going to have an ng switch
default
which says or something's wrong so i'll
let you know how that works
so for now let's just save this
and see um look at the output
so when you look at the browser it says
hey good morning today is tuesday smash
your goals
so since today is tuesday the day i'm
recording it it displays
uh this message however i can change it
that is i can customize it say for
example i can just
create another property here
let's say public date two
and let me just give uh the value five
five is basically friday
and here in my html i'll just change the
property to day two
and when i save this and
let's have a look now it says today is
friday thank god it's friday
so this is how you can customize it all
right so now to help you understand how
the ng switch default works
i have changed uh the property or day
two
and i've initialized it to seven now if
you look at the html file we haven't
provided any
uh switch case for seven right so
automatically it has to
display the default message that is
something is wrong
so now let's save this and have a look
at the browser you can see it says uh oh
something's wrong
so this is how ng switch works in
angular all right so that is it
for this session on angular ng switch if
you have any doubts or queries let us
know in the comment section below we'll
get back to you
immediately watch out for more videos
from us on the angular series
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here